infertility is an issue many couples go
through but it's usually not openly
talked about while Las Vegas woman is
using her struggles trying to get
pregnant and turning it into a
children's book it discusses this
sensitive topic in a child-friendly way
Victoria Saha has more tonight
Diana alexandrova and her boyfriend have
always wanted to be parents but that
common goal that many couples dream of
has now turned into a 10-year struggle
for them it took few years until I
realized that I'm not gonna get pregnant
very easily alexandrova says she has
tried everything in the last 10 years to
conceive Chinese herbs acupuncture
supplementary different diets it's hard
to accept that it's not happening she
isn't alone studies show 6.1 million
American women struggle with infertility
but alexandrova's struggles are being
voiced in a children's book called The
Lazy store inspired by an old Tale in
her home country of Bulgaria that big
birds like storks are the ones who
deliver babies to families I thought wow
that my stock is really late and I
decided to blame all my struggles on a
lazy Stark but because it's for kids I
wanted to be and playful funny way her
book is meant to offer hope to women
struggling to get pregnant and for
current siblings who are eagerly waiting
for their little brother or sister and
once they do come into the world it
would be hard to stay mad at the lazy
stork that took so long Victoria Saha 8
News Now
she tells Victoria she's currently
trying IVF as her last resort but is
keeping her faith strong the lazy stork
will be available to buy on Mother's Day